[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in peter king the must-read
every monday morning football morning in
america
columnist nbcsports.com what did you
hear in that speech peter
i heard the voice of the man who should
be but probably won't be the next
commissioner of the nfl
i mean there's just there's way too much
non-football stuff that peyton manning
would have to deal with
um i mean my first thought was that when
i was listening i said that's
that's something that people need to
hear and it's something particularly
from hall of famers many of whom just
say hey
thanks for the memories and walk away
and peyton manning said i'm not going to
walk away i want to
i want to pay tribute to this game i
want to help this game
make sure that it keeps its foothold in
american society
commissioner goodell signed that
extension so he's
in place for what four more years
yeah but look a lot of people believe
well i wrote about this maybe two months
ago
uh there are many people in the nfl who
think
that he's gonna work quite a bit longer
the general perception around the league
was once he got all the late
the new labor deal done all the media
deals done
you know after they finish doing
whatever they're going to do i think
they're probably going to spin off nfl
network
after they do all the mega things with
the league that he would walk away
the issue is goodell is whatever 63
he doesn't want to be an investment
banker he doesn't want to
you know work for a hedge fund he
doesn't want to spend the rest of his
life
golfing and being on 15 boards of
directors
in ceremonial positions he wants to do
something
and there's nothing else he wants to do
right now other than be the commissioner
yeah i just i was surprised that peyton
spent a third of his speech
almost a third of his speech with that
and it sounded commissioner-like there
uh
instead of hey we're waiting for him to
be a broadcaster be a general manager
it's like
maybe he has you know a bigger picture
there um
a couple of things here you got home on
friday night you leave this afternoon
you've been to vegas san francisco
dallas
la seattle denver kansas city
best stop so far and why
i'm fascinated by the los angeles
chargers i know
probably a lot of people and i know this
a lot of people the chargers are not on
their radar screen and i get it but
you know i spent a good portion of a
morning last monday
with brandon staley walking around the
building being in his office
sitting in on it on a meet a staff
meeting
and you know there's a lot of five years
ago he is the
defensive coordinator john carroll and
so
this is an incredible ascension but i
compare it to mike tomlin you know as
dan rooney once told me
if i don't hire mike tomlin now when
he's 34 years old
i'm never going to be able to hire him
so the chargers felt the same way with
staley
that plus i think justin herbert
obviously
he's probably a top 10 quarterback right
now he could be top five by the end of
the year
derwin james coming back joey bosa
trying to stay healthy
the adjustment to sophie will they have
a place in a very crowded sports market
the charges are fascinating but probably
the best
the biggest thing i did was lead to my
column today which was
essentially how the kansas city chiefs
are a model
for how you should treat your
quarterback and how your quarterback
should always be in partnership with the
team
speaking of which josh allen josh allen
signs that deal
and uh now next up is lamar jackson
baker mayfield and i know you wrote this
in the column
you know that doesn't necessarily mean
anything for lamar jackson and baker
mayfield but
how do you see that playing out with
both are these
no-brainers that their teams are going
to extend them
look i don't i mean to me it's very very
hard to
look at the career of baker mayfield
and say that it has a lot of
similarities
to uh patrick mahomes if i were the
browns i'd wait
it might cost him some money but do you
want to pay a guy
and do you want to end up getting carson
winst
you know and totally getting screwed on
your cap and all that stuff
and again i think the odds are
better than 50 50 that he will be the
browns long-term quarterback
but are you positive so i think you're
better off
having to pay whatever the number is
three million more per year
if you wait than paying baker mayfield
right now because i just think
looking at a season last year it ended
great but overall
it was a good to very good season but
are you positive right now that baker
mayfield is your franchise guy
why does the next guy have to make more
than the previous guy
it's it's what has always happened
in negotiating contracts in every sport
and i think the mahomes contract to some
degree stands alone
some people three years from now will be
above him probably
when certainly when the cap really
starts to go up
um but i just think it's look
it's all monopoly money anyway and look
if if josh allen is making 43 million a
year on average
if he's making 2.7 million dollars for
every football game he plays
it just it's not anything that really
occurs to me
that is uh that's outrageous
but it's it's it's it's the law of the
land in the nfl in every sport
that contracts never go down
particularly
when the salary cap goes up what was tom
brady
talking about alluding to where you're
looking at all the money that's being
made and forbes magazine ranking you
know all of these teams are worth at
least two billion dollars
but you know didn't tom use the word
idiots or idiotic
ignorant oh ignorant okay yeah i mean
i don't blame brady uh you know because
clearly look at it this way dan from the
time
that tom brady signed his contract to
now
and these are forbes magazine valuations
a lot of people in the nfl really take
these as gospel
but since the day he signed his contract
the tampa bay buccaneers are worth 720
million
more dollars than they were
uh the day that he signed so
i think brady just looks at that and
he says look the players are not getting
a cut
of these tremendous increases in
franchise value
wake up you know you but the the problem
now
is dan there's nothing you can do about
the salary cap until 2031.
if you want to rebel and the problem is
you know what
rebellion is it's telling the nfl you're
going on strike
and seriously taking a year off and
there's just not a majority of players i
think who are willing to do that
he's peter king his column football
morning in america and uh of course
works for nbc nbcsports.com
help me understand what's going to
happen with kirk cousins in minnesota
what can the vikings do
and uh how do you think this plays out
you know i just have very strong
opinions about this dan and i think that
if you are in the vital position
that kirk cousins is in with a team
then no matter how much and for whatever
reason it might be
that you don't want to take the vaccine
i just
i can't believe that you won't take the
vaccine
i mean if kirk cousins test positive and
is symptomatic
theoretically if he tests positive on a
friday he's going to miss two games
that is one eighth of his season
10 12 whatever it is it's now one
you know 2 17 which is a little less
than 1 8
but i just i can't reconcile that
i can't reconcile it and you know
my you can tell mike zimmer he's got to
walk a tightrope with this
and what is he going to do these only
alternative is
to say uh that this guy we're paying
eight gillion dollars a year to
uh we uh you know we're we're going to
start somebody else
it's it's not realistic it's not
pragmatic
how does the nfl ramp this up can they
ramp this up
pressure i mean the nfl would say look
we got
91 of players in the league we only have
on
average on a 90-man roster we only have
seven or eight players on average per
team
that have not been vaccinated that's
good the problem is
with the delta variant there's danger
now
you look at the rich eisen story you
know he's vaccinated he has a delta
variant
he and and he gets it and he passes it
on to his daughter
and it's just it really knocks them out
so
that's why even if you get vaccinated
the only thing it probably ensures
is that you're not going to die and
you're probably not going to get
seriously ill but you still can be a
spreader
uh you know of of coven so
you know we're in a tough time in this
country obviously
and i don't know what more the nfl can
do than it's already done
it's made players second-class citizens
who will not take the vaccine and that's
i don't know what else they can do i
know the cowboys
that they always make headlines and i
don't know if there's more to dak
prescott's injury
the video doesn't look good and the only
reason why i thought maybe there's more
to it was troy aikman said
it felt like there's more to this it
just
it feels like it's a vague report what's
it say to you
you know i was there i talked to him
about it
and there's nothing anybody can do right
now
i mean he's been thoroughly examined the
cowboys don't think it's
anything serious um but i mean
i think what you do here it's august 9th
if on august 20th he's either not
practicing
or uh he's practicing in a very limited
way
and he can't throw his fastball that's
when you're worried or august
23rd whatever it is you know if you get
to be two weeks before the season
and he's not practicing fully that's
when i would worry
uh before i let you go the michael
thomas situation with the saints is
certainly interesting and then he sent
out a tweet
and it said they tried to damage your
reputation you saved theirs by not
telling your side of the story
uh this why didn't i mean i guess i
would say why didn't he return their
phone calls for three months
why didn't he why did he not have
contact with them
for the majority of this off season why
is that a guy who is either and again
look we don't know the whole story
no one does but if it's true jeff duncan
reported this in new orleans that he
ghosted them for most of the off-season
i i
i what else do you need to hear isn't he
most concerned with getting his ankle
right
and getting ready for the start of the
season an injury
suffered on opening day 2020
yeah okay is has a good chance to ruin
two seasons when he's making 19 million
dollars a year
i mean there may be some
irresponsibility
on the part of the saints there may be
some but let's hear what it is
uh because right now they don't appear
to be the responsible party they might
be
or the irresponsible party they might be
but let's
let's hear the evidence first it feels
like they could be really good or a mess
maybe there's there's no room in between
for the for this friend
you know this let's say jameis winston
plays you know i remember dirk cutter
for five years not me what he didn't
have him for five years but
it is so but at the beginning he had a
meeting with james winston
and before they drafted him in tampa he
was offensive coordinator
and he asked james he said hey i've
looked at all your tape at florida state
is there any throw you're afraid of
making and he goes
no not a single one and cutters said
well maybe there should be and he meant
that he didn't mean that to
slap him in the face but he meant to say
man you make some careless throws
and five years later what is he doing
still making careless throws
i mean the last throw he made as a
member of the tampa bay buccaneers
was a pick six that handed a win to the
atlanta falcons in overtime
so i we have not seen anything it's
wonderful to say well he's with sean
payton now everything's fine
how do we know he hasn't played football
games
you know he's played cameo appearances
but we don't have any idea we don't know
if taysom hill can play
so the one thing that has been an
absolutely sure thing
for the new orleans saints for a decade
and a half now all of a sudden
we really don't have any idea what's
going to happen when one of those guys
steps under center
pete's off to buffalo green bay
indianapolis chicago minnesota that's
the next nine days the next nine days
it'll be a good time
do you get uh some time with rogers
i don't know i've requested him but you
know that's up to him whether he
wants to spend any time with me whatever
a long time ago dan i'm 64 years old
and a long time ago i said to myself
i'm not going to fight to interview
anybody
i'd like to interview everybody and i
and i submit my
request to the pr people and if it
happens it happens if not
hey it's a free country what if he says
you got two questions pete
what do you want to ask
uh where will you be on march 1st 2022
what's your prediction and um
you're not going to get a second
question after that well
i mean you asked me what my questions
would be oh i know but i'm saying rogers
won't let you have the second one after
yeah
i mean i would have to think about this
because
aaron rodgers is so smart that
he would i wouldn't get an answer you're
right
so to ask a question like that quite
honestly is useless
that would be a very very interesting
thought i'd have to think about that
but that'd be fine if he says he got two
questions i remember
dan i don't know this is maybe three
years ago bart starr was still alive
and i went through set for football
night in america they wanted me to do
a roger's story for opening night you
know they
they were kicking off the season uh
playing on opening night
and they said to me see if you can get
rogers to do some sort of story
and i thought of about five different
things
and every one i was at his locker
explaining here how about this
and everyone he's saying no to but
finally i said
how about if i get you to talk about
bart starr in the meaning in his life he
goes
well that one i'll do and i went to see
bart starr
got the last sort of difficult interview
with bart star
ever and then came back and it was a
pretty touching story but
look aaron rodgers loves the history of
the green bay packers
loves it and he i think he really loves
the people of green bay
so you know we'll see how it all turns
out my feeling is
he's probably somewhere else in 2022 but
we'll see